today we are going to have
a creative project q and a
uh and we do have a little guest with us
and it's brayden may who is a concept
artist
say hello brayden hello
this is braden's art so this is who
we'll be chatting to today
i want it to be a little bit more
professional because in the future we
will be having different people on so
this is going to be exciting i've
already got someone in the works and i
thought brady would be really good for
this one so this is the kind of work
that he does he's a concept artist do
you want to explain like a bit about
what you do
counterclock
is someone who uses 2d or 3d to
i guess design
anything from characters to environment
to props
that
like then gets passed on to a 3d artist
so
any of these pictures not like this
exactly but as he's showing could be
theoretically passed on to a 3d artist
or then model it
texture it and then it'll get put in a
game
um
but
like normally in my personal work which
is the stuff you have shown now i can
never be bothered to go
like full concept artist mode so these
are just like rough sketches and stuff
or
well
yeah and this is what we'll talk about
today we'll talk about
finishing our creative projects for
braden that is this this is his
instagram his pieces of art you know and
and
probably part of that is that he he
knows what's manageable for him so what
he does is what he does on his
day-to-day job it's a little bit
different from what he does in his
personal time and um i think that's a
really healthy way of working um but
yeah i really like these
posts that you do like where you have
your concept art and then you have what
inspired the concepts are
because i think a lot of people who
aren't artists think that artists just
like sit down and draw amazing things
which you do but you know
you you have to have reference images
and and there's this so i love that you
that you share that like this milk truck
um turned into milk
robots which is cool
so the first question that i want um to
hear
what you think about
and to open up with is
why do we not finish a project is there
any projects that that you work on that
you haven't finished and why haven't you
finished that or what do you think in
general why do people not finish
creative projects most of the time we
procrastinate
because we're like fearful
of of perhaps doing something wrong or
you know it actually is very important
to us
and that's what denise has just
mentioned
oh where
uh
many stop due to insecurities and yeah
about themselves or the specific piece
exactly yeah that is that is like spot
on yeah 28 said it could be a mix of
uninteresting boring things attached to
the ones you do like that's so true as
well every project will have like fun
bits and not so fun bits you're gonna
have to do both to get the project
finished
i think unfortunately it's
like an inevitability
oh absolutely yeah it really is
gabaranto art said um same here i get i
get to the point that i need to study
and practice more and leave it for later
i think that it's personal like
that is perfectly reasonable um i put
things on the back burner all the time
when i realized that actually i might
need to
learn a bit more or like be at a
different level you can always come back
to it though
um but yeah we can talk about that a bit
later as well i think
for a lot of people
and
i think myself included especially when
it comes to sharing projects online
because usually a lot of people nowadays
with social media and the internets uh
think that the project is like finished
when it's out there um you know it's out
there for people to see to give you
feedback on or to potentially like
criticize you know which is always a bit
scary for for artists yeah what do you
think braden that can be sometimes why
oh well sometimes why i don't even start
a project because i have ideas in my
head and i'm just like i just know i
at the moment probably won't be able to
achieve that which is probably not a
great thing in itself because
if i start a project at least give it a
go and then so it might not be what's
him ahead but i can always come back to
it in a year or two or whatever when i'm
more skilled in doing it whatever yeah
yeah no that's a very good point so
before this i got i got a screenshot of
some of my um
hate comments and you know it does
happen the weirdest the best advice i
got about like receiving hate on things
is actually that when you start
receiving hate a lot of the time unless
you actually evoking work to try and
like creating work to evoke hate and i
i'm not
saying that you should do that please
don't do that um but usually it means
that actually
you're you're getting somewhere because
people are noticing and
i don't know why they do it but they do
it if you're big enough for them to
notice if that makes sense so whenever i
get hate i try and always remember like
you know
like like i've said to braden with my
some of my previous videos have like
gotten quite a lot of views now over a
hundred thousand and that's amazing but
with that comes so much hate so much
hate
um but that's okay because that also
means that it was successful and i want
to show you this quote from stephen king
which is
um he was 40 before he realized that
almost every writer of fiction and
poetry and basically any creative person
right um who has ever published a line
has been accused of someone of wasting
his or her god-given talent so if you
if you are creative someone will try to
make you feel lousy about it and that is
all and that is so so true
like it's just really true and it's just
the way that it is you just kind of have
to like accept it and move on and focus
on the nice comments because there are
loads of nice comments and um
one thing that you'll notice is the nice
comments versus the
most of the hate comments they could
have constructive criticism but that's
constructive criticism and they're
usually coming from people who are doing
the same things as you they understand
the time dedication and effort that it
took for you to
to make that thing
so
you know they they have more of an
understanding and they can actually give
you criticism that isn't just like this
is poop they can be like hey i really
like this bit but i think this bit needs
a bit more of
this and that you know
and
there's there's many times when i've
had to remind uh yes about the good
comments because i don't know what it is
about humans but they just tend to focus
on the negative and i know a lot of
youtubers do this and they just
scroll through all the nice stuff but
there'll be one comment saying how
crap the video was or whatever and i
just focus on that and ignore the 100 of
comments saying how enjoyable it was
that was good oh also i also wanted to
mention if you really struggle with
motivation before we
dive into all the little little nuances
of giving you tips on how to be
motivated um
do like if you think that it could be
something medical then do like phone
your doctor people with adhd have focus
problems um if you have mental health
issues that that could affect your
motivation and that is not something
that
can be fixed overnight you know that's
not something you should beat yourself
up about over either
um really be kind to yourself and talk
to a doctor so i just wanted to get that
out of the way also if you're a woman or
if you menstruate i should say
um then that really can affect your
motivation as well if i'm you know
doing my my period season i'm not
i'm not feeling motivated i'm just
feeling in pain so um there is that too
and there's a lot of really good
information out there around um
menstruation and how you can work with
that to actually
um increase your motivation around the
times that you are ovulating because
actually we're more inclined to like um
be motivated when we're ovulating so
the more you know human bodies amazing
hormones
i just want to give some general
time management and planning tips
um no one actually asked any questions
about this but i think it's it's pretty
important so i've just put some bullet
points down
because i think time management and
burnout is another main reason that
people don't finish their projects they
they expect to maybe be done in like a
few weeks and actually it's gonna take
them like a few months that happens all
the time
um so my main bullet points if you don't
mind me just rattling through them
braden are you okay with that yeah sure
perfect break down your project into
small tasks
and then create mini deadlines for each
of the small tasks so whether that be
like every chapter of your book or
getting your models finished for a game
or having the first pass of lyrics
recorded for a song once you have your
small task accounted for make a soft
deadline for the overall project
um
that you can hold yourself accountable
to
and uh
always add contingency to that overall
timeline make sure that you have time in
there to be social to have you time
that's not just working especially if
you have a full-time job alongside doing
your project
um and
write it out in a written schedule that
will remind you like i find this very
helpful anyway so i put it into google
calendar and then i'll get like a bing
and it will tell me what i have to do
that day or you know i have a deadline
coming up and then on the day that you
are supposed to be
uh working then write a to-do list down
i like to do this physically i don't
know something nice about it just so
that you're not overwhelmed on what work
you have to do that day and you don't
overwork yourself because you just keep
to the to-do list
try to try them and not make it too long
though
uh and then yeah just re-evaluate your
timeline and your schedule on google
calendar or wherever you've decided to
do it
and keep reassessing if you have to push
back the deadlines that's perfectly fine
like don't beat yourself up
um yeah be kind to yourself and that's
my time management and planning tips
a lot of things very good
and
to
go back what you said earlier i
have none at all because of my personal
work i don't do any of that stuff i
have it ready when it's ready basically
um
but yeah if you do need time management
stuff
follow yazzy's advice
see these are two completely different
people i need deadlines i i really do
because i'll get lost and i'll get
overwhelmed and i
will over scope myself
you don't ever tend to do that to
yourself
no i guess that's
because
i don't time management so if
something is going to take me a long
time it's perfectly fine for that
or
you know if i do get bored like
it's fine for me to drop it
you are just the kindest person to
yourself that i know it's it's wonderful
i never really thought about that but
here you are
you give yourself enough you know you're
just like i can't make it today that's
okay i'll do it tomorrow
yeah it's a really nice way to be i i
wish there was some
advice you can give us well is there any
advice you can give us to be a bit more
chill
for me personally like i'm literally
doing it just for me
like i i don't have any
i don't see me posting to instagram is
like a thing or i don't do youtube or
whatever so
i'm just doing it for me and eventually
if
i do have something to post anywhere
it's that's cool i'll do it but yeah
it's it's all just for me so that is
actually a really good segue to
figuring out why you create
thanks for that
it's our first question
um so the great
gabsby
which is a really cool name anyway said
how do you manage to keep confident in
your project without any external
feedback i have self-esteem issues and
constantly think i'm wasting my time on
a project that won't go anywhere and i
have no one to tell if i have no one to
tell me if what i'm doing has any merit
or appeal first of all i would say
there's something quite interesting
about that ques um that question because
uh
the great gapsby says
they worry that it won't go anywhere
and that like
just i i would like this person to
explore that more like where would they
want that project to go if it was
finished
like who are they
making it for or what are they making it
for is it a film and they wanted to be
at a film festival
um
and you know
who are they who are you making
something for if it's not for yourself
because usually everything we make is
for ourselves we're usually that's my
own interpretation of
art anyway
um
but yeah i think this person can get
some really great introspection if they
like tackle those questions
where do they want it to go and who are
they making it for we watched kiki's
delivery service the other day and i
thought this quote was was beautiful for
this question and it's it's a quote in
kiki's delivery service and they say we
actually need to find our own
inspiration
sometimes it's not easy and it's so true
because sometimes we do lose inspiration
you know
artists will not want to draw anymore
musicians won't want to sing or play
music
game develop developers won't want to
develop they won't want to open up a
game engine for a while
and a lot of that is because maybe
they've
forgotten why they enjoyed it in the
first place i think we all go through
this sometimes and really we do have to
figure out why
it is we create what are we doing it for
what what does it
bring provide us
because it's probably not money
that's for sure
yeah unfortunately unfortunately
it's
i think that is the important part like
the important thing is why are you
why are you doing it exactly
if
i'm sure everyone eventually would like
to
be the next stephen king or
you know a big film director but
until then you just really have to
love the process of whatever you're
doing absolutely yeah and you know
to be the next
stephen king or you know whoever whoever
it is you have to bring something that's
completely unique to the table because
that's what they brought right so you
have to find that first
within you
yeah
and i think when you say completely
unique it doesn't have to be like
something revolutionary
it's just
maybe
maybe you look at the world or just
something slightly differently to
stephen king and it's just enough to
make
your work a bit different from his yeah
that's i think that's perfectly fine and
perfectly good to make you obviously
stand out and people want to see your
stuff absolutely absolutely
um also
i'm just gonna say you know i also
understand that
this person was asking how how do they
say motivated when they go don't get
feedback so i also do want to say it's
totally fine to get feedback when your
project isn't finished yet it doesn't
have to be feedback from
other artists in that field or creators
in that field you know you can get
you can get feedback from your family
from your friends people that you trust
really especially if it's still not
finished yet because
uh it won't be in a finished state
um but yeah you you can definitely show
show other people i mean even someone
who doesn't know the craft can still
give you a viewer's perspective um which
is really valuable
yeah 100
um
like
so if i wanted feedback on a like an art
piece i'm doing something if i went to
an artist i could get more technical
feedback
and like uh you know our perspective
wrong these colors are bad blah blah
blah blah but if i went to i don't know
say my mom
she'd be like oh yeah this is great or
she might be like i don't understand
what you're trying to
do here or yeah you know
it's it's just like i guess depending
what sort of feedback you want depends
who you should go to
and like i said like even someone not in
the field can perfectly
have good advice for you even if it's
not like oh this is wrong or this is
wrong it's just like oh i'm not seeing
it or i thought this was happening
and i think you know people that you
respect by that i don't mean people who
are just going to say yes yes yes all
the time i mean people who are going to
have your best interest at heart so
they're not just going to turn around
and say that's bad you know they might
say oh i'm not sure about this or
whatever but you
respect and and trust them enough to
know that what they're going to say is
from the goodness of their hearts and
you know
very important yeah yeah trust at least
you know they're honest yeah yes exactly
yeah
um
going off this
you said you create for you but like
what are the reasons you create i just
have a
idea in my head sometimes a stupid idea
and i'm just like i have to get this
onto paper
so just the simple fact of being
creative you just want to
create
yeah probably
um
maybe part of it is also some like
really bad stubbornness just to get
better at being
creative i've done it for so long now i
can't give up essentially so i want to
get better with it so i've got to create
stuff to get better at it
like a vicious loop
fair enough fair enough i don't have a
solid answer oh it's still a motivating
way to look at it because you're looking
at it as you know i've spent time in
this and i i know where i want to be in
the future so i simply just want to
carry on
and that's that's good this is the thing
you don't have to have some mind-blowing
like amazing reason like you know
oh i
i don't know i
something really crazily dramatic
happened in my life and then i realized
i wanted to be an artist don't mean
anything like that it can be as simple
as you know i've already
done
a year of art or whatever i realize i
like it more than something else than
anything else so i might as well just
carry on in here so yeah
fair enough yeah that's how i fell into
it yeah i spent two years drawing i'm
not going to give up yeah exactly and i
think like the reason that i create is i
just want to learn more so it's very
similar to i just want to i like
learning i like to see what new things i
can learn a lot of artists i know say
one of the best ways to sort of learn
themselves is to
almost
teach other people
yeah like a lot of artists stay do a lot
of paint overs and stuff and say that's
a great way
for them to just
figure out like what their like their
thought process and stuff so absolutely
yeah yeah
i bet you making them videos helps you
just cement the idea even further it
does
it does i have to look into every detail
um but yeah and then also just you know
to express my emotions learn more about
myself i definitely learn about myself
when i'm writing songs
um and just writing in general i think
helps me learn about myself and
that might sound really narcissistic but
i think we all have something to learn
we can all learn more about the way we
are what makes us tick how we feel
processing emotions you know they're
very complicated so art can help so this
is our next question from
rowley
tormas
uh where do you get your inspiration
from
very simple question but a very
complicated answer i am sure
anything you want to share on
at the start this time for me personally
my inspiration uh it's cheesy comes from
the
the
the world i guess
you know
things around me whatever
and then
some people might take that
as like
oh you've gotta go to
crazy exhibitions and museums and travel
but i don't think that's necessarily the
case
even
like
where was it
when we
was in
um
we went to the shops and there was like
a lift with a glass case thing
and i was just looking at it and i was
like i have some really cool like
mechanical stuff going in there
that's like really
not inspiring but it was like i could
look at this take a picture and use it
for designs like as a person who likes
mechanical stuff just a lifting boots
was like
inspiration almost for something that i
could design
yeah
you don't have to like fly on a plane
and go to
like all the crazy places and spend
money to find inspiration you just have
to figure out
what what you like and then people look
out but as you're walking around
i absolutely agree um
i think
you're the more inspiration you can get
from the world
and i mean
you you want to live as well so you want
to understand
you know
different ways of living how how people
think how people tick
um because at the end of the day
i mean if you do hope to be the next big
thing or you want to at least
create things that touch people's hearts
you have to understand those people at
first you need to
make your work relatable in some sort of
way i mean we've we've mentioned stephen
king he's only ever lived in maine is it
he's never lived anywhere else and
that's made him extremely good at
building communities within his world
because
he's been brought up within a community
from for his whole life he he
understands how it changes and grows
throughout the years he understands how
relationships like wane and come back
together
he's experienced that and he's very good
at writing about it his characters are
always extremely in-depth
um
yeah so the world is a is a very good
answer
and of course
as you've said in
the document other artists and just
other people
oh yeah totally i i also think i think
it's very um it's a very good idea to
try if you can to get inspiration from
like people who are big yeah but also
small so they don't have to be stephen
king levels are big you know if there's
someone that's a bit more on your level
that inspires you i think that's really
healthy because you're also giving
yourself um a bar that's a little bit
more realistic for you to do because you
ha you don't have x amount of years of
experience or a triple a studio behind
you you know
all these big people that we look up to
a lot of them do work with many other
people and usually when we start out
we don't we're working alone most of the
time so keep that in mind and if you
can't find any small people to find
inspiration from
who are doing similar things to you then
try to educate yourself on the history
of people who do inspire you so
um yeah yeah the history of artists so
where did they come from how far did
they come did they
uh did they go to uni or did they do all
these things i mean it was a real
turning point for me when i realized
that tim burton who was my
when i was in like secondary school he
was a big inspiration to me
and um
he worked with another writer to write
the nightmare before christmas and
edward scissorhands and he came up with
the characters but he didn't actually
come up with a screenplay or anything um
and a lot of he actually wasn't there on
set most of the time when they were
filming nightmare before christmas
because he was working on batman at the
same time and then i realized
oh
i don't have to do everything on my own
you know it's a yeah it's really good if
you can educate yourself on things like
that the next question is
do you know how i can pick a good video
game idea so
i mean this is specifically about video
games but i think this can be about
anything
how can we come up with the
quote-unquote
good idea
and i i know this can this can be a
roadblock before people have even
started they you know a roadblock to
them finishing because they come up with
so many ideas they don't know which one
is the good one
they feel like maybe they can't even
come up with one good one what is
the good one
and how do we find it it's as you said
it's
no one can tell you
yeah so
i i don't think i i'd love to say this
would be a great idea and people will
say that you know like you can look at
the the um the analytics of like what
people are playing right now what's
popular right now blah blah blah and
then that would be a quote on quote good
idea or more i would say a safe idea
but i i don't think that's necessarily a
good idea especially if you're just
making a creative project
um for yourself that you'll be investing
a lot of time in especially a video game
a video game is going to take you a long
time
i would imagine at least a year
unless it's an extremely simple one and
you don't have a full-time job
but yeah not many people can tell you
what idea to do that really is
something that you have to come up with
yourself and i'm sorry that's such a you
know it's a meh answer but you just have
to make sure that the project is
something that you feel you'll gain from
either emotionally or through
progressing a certain skill like i say i
enjoy learning new things
so
um yeah if you don't have this then you
do run the risk of becoming bored
becoming disinterested
um just like we spoke about in the
beginning of this video just becoming
completely disinterested with the whole
project if you don't have something that
um
that you're getting from it
if that makes sense
yeah
i agree and you know make sure
you're passionate about it and then if
you do decide to show the world
i guess
people either love it or
not hate it but you know
yeah it's it's
i guess it's like most stuff
i put out on instagram sometimes like oh
it's a fantastic idea everyone's gonna
love it and no one gives a [ __ ] but the
thing i'm like is all right
you know might kick off
you never know
you never know why
yeah it's as you said it's impossible
for any one person to say this is good
or bad yeah exactly art is so subjective
every type of art is so subjective
and um yeah it kind of goes back to why
are you creating so
yeah
as long as you're putting action into it
then
there should be
you know some good in it
yeah like like um miyazaki
the how do you live that's still in
development
um it's just uh
i
i read on the times
that apparently
the question was posed to him saying oh
are you
um
going to be showing us what it what it
means how do you live are you going to
be answering this question and then he
said no i'm actually making this movie
because i don't have the answer so he's
using this movie to explore
how do you live like to explore that
question and to try and come out come up
with the answer
through his creative process so that's
like his drive and you know that is a
brilliant drive because why would you
want to stop
you know stop making that project
because you're essentially trying to
learn something about yourself something
about how you view the world something
that um
you know that makes you tick
rick's a lie
the rachel light says i've had a story
in my head for 13 years i've put some
ideas down but don't know the full story
this could be a hard one to answer but
how do you think i should go about
writing it so i mean obviously this is
very specific to writing but i think a
lot of people can um can relate you know
you you research something for a very
long time you might be like learning how
to make music or a game
um you know how to how to art by
following tutorials and stuff how to art
um
and then it comes to actually wanting to
get an a unique idea down and you don't
know where to begin
so this yeah this is a great question
thank you rexella as you said here is
talking like he had a good
like massive idea for the world and he
had it all figured out
and
eventually he just had to start writing
stories with it and
yeah i think researching to a degree is
really good but eventually you do have
to just
start
start putting a pencil to a paper or
something just so
you can get it out otherwise
it's just going to be
you know
like stuck in a big binder somewhere
just random notes and stuff yeah no
one's going to read that
absolutely like um
so i've done i've done a lot of research
on like how other people write how other
people create and through every single
time i've looked into someone's history
they have never known all of the
intricate details of their creative
project
um before they started they've always
known
maybe like the main beats or like in in
a game you'll know the game pillars
um but really you have to dig into it to
understand what the project is and to to
see how it's going to look or sound or
feel whatever it is um outside of your
head you just need to get it outside of
your head like stephen king
um he describes his process as like
watching his characters i said he's very
character driven that's what he's good
at so what he does is he comes up with
his characters he just starts to write
them down and then he even says that
he's he's surprised by the the choices
that his characters take sometimes and
that's just his
writing process and then miyazaki's
films um he doesn't write the screenplay
first he just makes a bunch of
drawings like really really beautiful
ones because for him it's all about the
atmosphere
capturing the look and feel of it and
then from there he'll he'll see where
the story um goes like where it pops out
of the pictures and then like bin just
mentioned tolkien
he was writing excerpts of of middle
earth for a long long time because he's
in the army and stuff
um and then one day he just got
inspiration and just wanted to write
this sentence in a hole in the ground
that lived a hobbit and he just kept
writing um
and i think that's also what i want to
say as well don't think that your first
piece of work has to be your grandest or
your biggest or the best i mean
tolkien's was hobbit which is like a
small quote-unquote kid's book i don't
know if it
it's just a kid's book but that's what
people say and then obviously when he
went on to write much much grander
in-depth
novels
um
and they'd actually been in his head the
whole entire time but he wrote the
hobbit first
so yeah don't put so much pressure on
yourself for the first thing to like be
amazing
because we watch the behind the scenes
of the lord of the rings films and it
goes into talking stuff
and you see a lot of
uh
like comments from his publishers and
even they said like the early lord of
the rings books and whatever were not
fantastic so talking
you know was rewriting them editing
stuff fixing it up and
i think
if you sort of stuck in that like depth
sort of uh what would you say that
you're actually frozen with creativity
because you don't know where to start i
think you should start writing it and as
you said even if it's not
fantastic the first time there's nothing
stopping you
doing it again rewriting it editing it
starting a picture again whatever
absolutely yeah yeah totally like it's
all about seeing what you learn from it
right like um i know tolkien was also
very a big fan of sharing his work and
getting feedback from people that he
trusted like we talked about trust
earlier and um
i'm writing a
my first
short story at the moment and i thought
about the idea for a long time as well
wixolite and um
i ended up just joining a qrik group
which it sounds formal but it's not real
it's just with a bunch of friends who i
have who also wanted to write their own
stories and had never gotten around to
it so we all just said okay we're going
to meet up every few months hold
ourselves accountable read each other's
chapters and give each other some
feedback and that's tolkien did that a
lot and that really helped him and yeah
i would say if you don't know where to
start
if you do ha know anyone else that's in
the same boat it doesn't have to be with
the same thing they don't have to be
writing it could be like one person's
doing a song and the other person's you
know making a game or whatever it's more
about just holding each other
accountable and then also being there to
be a trusted ear to to give feedback to
yeah
the next one how to overcome the
creator's block we've all been here and
we hate it it sucks
leon cartel
reborn
how do you find motivation to keep on
working on something like a project
even when you think it's not working out
or that it doesn't live to the
expectations that you've set for it
i just want to say
nothing i have ever made in my entire
life
has lived up to the expectations that i
had set for it so i just want to get
that out there right now before we start
talking about it that's perfectly normal
i think
yep
everything i create just goes yeah it's
all right
yeah
yeah
that's that's the most i'll ever reaches
yeah it's okay i guess yeah i'd be like
you know what this it's all right but
it's it's never like this is the exact
thing that i had envisioned oh my god
yep i don't think yeah i don't know
maybe once you get to the level where
you're like a ceo of your own
like company or you like you're very
high up and you have like massive teams
helping you
realize your vision maybe then you'll
get that but um
but yeah most of the time
you are gonna feel like you didn't do
everything that you wanted to do but
like try not to focus on that like i've
said before try to focus on what you're
learning and what you have done that's
new and how well you actually have done
along the way because every creative
piece is as a new endeavor you've never
done it before even if it is the same
drawing singing writing whatever you
know
i mean i will share i did get up here
um the only thing that
i think
um
[Music]
was kind of close to my expectations
was um
my song
of well the music video for close your
eyes
yeah yeah close your eyes because it was
just like supe a super simple idea
it's just kind of the sun sets over this
this
2d scene
and we have like a whale jumping and
yeah it looked pretty much like how i
envisioned it but
i made my
like my idea for it was super super
um
easy
so
if you are really worried about that
and you want to make sure you reach your
expectations make sure that you you
hinder those expectations like you reel
them back you make them more realistic
but you can only do that with um
i experience i think because you don't
know what you can do until you start
doing you know so unfortunately
it's a mindset that you kind of develop
as you continue to make things so this
is another reason why i will say to
people like just do just whatever you
want to do please just keep doing it
because not only do you learn the craft
better and you get better in what you're
doing but also you know you do develop
this mindset you kind of you understand
how long things will take you to do
you you start to develop a thicker skin
you start to understand what is
realistic within your your boundaries
and your limitations
you just learn a lot about yourself
along the way as well as the craft that
you want to get good at resisting the
yellow of a new idea new idea a new idea
a new idea it's actually an extension of
the previous question that we had and it
says it was two questions and one
how to not drop a game after i start
being passionate about it
so a lot of people like they'll start on
a creative project
and then they'll think of a new product
and they'll go oh
i like this new project even though i
only just started a project yesterday
but i'm finding it boring already
so i think it's a good idea that we we
chat about this
oh
yeah that picture sums it up perfectly
yeah exactly yeah
uh
it's
it's very tough
i will say that starting off with uh
yeah
but
like i think there's a lot of
nuances with the actual question no one
sees is that a word did i just make yeah
that nuance this is the way oh sweet
cool but
like if if you just started a project
and you're already thinking about a new
one
from my in my opinion it's perfectly
fine just be like ah i'm gonna do this
other thing because
that new project is in your head you're
excited about it clearly
just do it
but
you know
it depends how
how long you've spent on this other
project
as i said yeah just a day you've not
lost much but i know yes some of your
projects and i've got months
so you're not going to get halfway
through a video or something and go ah
i'm gonna forget this
yeah exactly um
i feel like it's there's also another
part to that which is if you do that
often then you might want to rethink you
know what what you're doing and why
you're doing it because
changing projects like every other day
that's not healthy and and you're not
going to get to finish anything so i
think you do need to exercise a bit of
restraint there
um
yeah yeah because i guess i guess from
from my point of view most of my
drawings i'd post out of like a day's
work so it's not that
much of an issue like i can generally
get through an image and i'll be fine
with it
but like i just feel like your projects
are much longer than yeah i agree
it's
probably worth trying to stick it out
even
even for my own experience when i've on
a bigger project that i'm doing
personally
um
if i am completely bored of it i'll
give it a day or two
just see if i can like
get something out of it yeah yeah
i'm working on a little project now i've
a bit bored of it and i'm just like ah
i'll give it a couple of hours and then
all of a sudden i thought of an
interesting idea
that sort of kick-started the passion
for it again
and there you go yeah yeah
exactly um i actually
so i think games especially are like a
massive undertaking this this question
was about video game development it's a
massive undertaking especially if you
have a full-time job um i mean there's a
reason why i haven't created a game yet
or haven't
delved into it yet properly
since after uni because it would take me
over a year to develop a game like on my
own um working full-time it's it's a
massive undertaking and you know the
longer
a piece of work takes the more
distracted you can probably become
because you're you're going to end up
getting less passionate about it as time
goes on so i would just say like before
switching ideas
stop working on it for a while first of
all
to allow yourself to have those fresh
eyes and you know to enjoy life again go
back to the inspiration part and bla bla
all those things um and then um yeah
consider changing parts of the project
instead of the whole project like if if
you had a cool new idea is there a part
of that idea that you can incorporate
into what you're already working on
that could be a good way around it
yeah i agree it's
again it's why most of my projects are
often really short because i have a
terrible attention span i actually
remembered you know that i guess there
are projects
that i have
not stopped working on but put on the
back burner i mean i have so many video
ideas that i've already started the
script of
and then i just don't follow through
with it so i guess that's kind of my
projects that i haven't followed through
it's more the script stage because then
you haven't really committed to anything
so yeah exactly that's that's what i'm
saying you know you spend a couple of
hours on it or not
yeah
yeah
and then i and then i might get a new
idea
and go this is so much better and um
yeah
so
sometimes new ideas aren't bad but yeah
i guess it's just have you actually
finished a project though are you
finishing projects as well as sometimes
getting distracted by new ideas
yes tough tough one to manage but
yeah with longer projects
try and stick with it and try and use
the fact that you've worked on it for so
long as a
mo as a motivator of like come on i've
spent months of my life on this on my
life on this thing
i really
should try and at least get it done to
some sort of state
yep i agree yeah and i also i just want
to say about video games as well um if
if this is your first like video game or
major
dev project uh whether that's like a
video cinematic in a game engine or
something
view it as a prototype it will really
help you because if you start to view
this as like some big game that's going
to be on steam uh you'll get really
overwhelmed not just about the project
but also about the engine and like
probably the folder structure and stuff
it'll start to get messy and you'll go
oh my gosh i can't work like this i have
to start again
to make everything like nicer and easier
to work with with which yes i do agree
with that but finish the game first
because you don't really know where it's
going to go
um
what was that um youtube channel you
told me about who's doing game dev and
he did just that
yeah so i was actually thinking of this
as you're saying it uh game maker's
toolkit
he's he does a lot of like in-depth look
into like game design ideas and stuff
like that and he's finally started to
make his own game
and
he's
realized oh my god this is stupidly hard
and uh
like even just getting
like a little
uh mvp minimum viable product out yeah
and from that he's realized like oh my
god i need to do this better and it's
better
yeah which is a much better way to do it
because he can now he's his last video
which i've watched today he's made a
bunch of tools
which has really helped him create
levels and stuff which is he was
struggling with before yeah so yeah but
the thing is you you do have to go
through that process of making a really
messy prototype because you need you
need to know what you want and you are
going to end up changing designs cutting
stuff out of the game like rearranging
things and it's going to end up being
messy but then once you know what you
want to make and you really understand
the game you're making then you know you
know what the folder structure should be
what is needed what isn't needed and you
just talked about tools what type of
tools are needed because you need to
understand what these tools actually
need to assist with as well
you know i'll link the channel in the
chat
yeah go for it
yeah it's
i've just linked it it's a really uh
a really good channel just to sort of
especially his latest videos just get an
insight into game dev
and i think he's doing some really good
steps as you said and then of course um
if you're still unsure and you don't
know if you should just like move on to
a new idea because you're unsure about
your current game or you think the new
idea would be better or whatever
then yeah talk to people that you trust
sometimes just hearing someone's opinion
on the thing you're working on or like
seeing their reaction to the thing that
you're working on will reignite your
passion because you'll be like oh this
is what it's like for someone to see the
thing that i've been working on with
fresh eyes you know with with no
understanding
a lot of people put um updates on social
media on twitter you don't have to do
that but i i could definitely see that
as being a massive motivator because if
you
put a video up on twitter saying like
hey i just added new animation to my
character and then people are going oh
wow that's so cool i love how the tail
moves or something
and then you're like oh you know
it's just a little confidence boost and
just help you along you know yeah i i
agree eve like on the on the i can't
stop saying like oh my god
i'm the big projects i think as you said
sharing work in progress stuff is
a good a good idea
yeah and it makes you less
um protective over your work as well
because you get into that routine of
just sharing and just not not
hopefully
well i can say not being a scared you're
always scared i'm still scared i was
scared before i live stream today um but
it becomes more normal so yeah and
you're gonna get more feedback more
people looking at your projects maybe
some people cheering you on
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah
yes
well again it's completely up to you if
you do want to share stuff
yeah i'm saying you have to yeah and you
can share stuff too you could even make
like a group chat with your like your
trusted friends your trusted colleagues
family members you know it doesn't have
to be social media either
good point yeah this is the last
question now
knowing when to finish so the question
is from david heaton how do you actually
finish a song so this is about a song
but i think it's a very good question to
ask about any creative project
when is it finished when should i
release it when should i
tell everyone that my big thing that
i've been working on for a long time is
done
uh and it's very difficult because i
mean my answer would be a creative piece
of work is never finished
one does not finish art
one says
ah that will do donkeys again
eats out
so that they can start on a new project
that's
basically basically it
yeah it's it's very true
i always get to a point where i'm like
i'm sort of bored or i don't know
how else to push it
any further and then as you said eat it
out
and move on to something else
yeah exactly it's
it's really difficult because it is more
of a feeling it just kind of feels right
like you know that you know there's
always something more you can do but you
like i cannot stress please do not work
on the same thing
for years and years and years when you
could have made like three or four
different things and then learnt more
from making all those new things and
then
progressed more unless you really feel
like like it's worth it for you and
that's absolutely fine um
but yeah there's always something you
can change so you really do have to give
yourself some leeway to i don't hit a
hundred percent
um just hit like 80 of your expectation
you know
yeah and as you as we said earlier it's
very rare anything would create ever
hits our expectations in our head
yeah
so
like figuring out how to
i guess manage them but also help you
understand when something might be
finished yeah exactly and if you can't
rely on the feeling because maybe you
haven't you know you haven't exercised
that you haven't like done a lot of
projects or you just don't trust
yourself yet it's fine um then the soft
deadline really works i mean that's one
reason that i
i used to be a perfectionist i am still
battling with that now it's not a good
thing it's not a good thing um so soft
deadlines are like wonderful because
i'll always tell myself that something
needs more work and it's you know oh
crap i messed up there and this isn't
good enough blah blah blah but if i'm
already at my soft deadline i have to
look at it from the perspective of like
okay i want it to be done by now because
i have like a backlog of stuff that i'm
really excited to work on
so
is it actually worth me spending more
time on this thing or or is it done you
know i i get to look at it from that
perspective instead of just like beating
myself about every little thing just
like no i've reached my deadline i
should be done now am i done and then
you know
i ask myself
um
yeah a good tip with that is if you're
at that point
and then you've done this with me
sometimes you ask me to look at it
and then you're like what about this
look at this is wrong and i'm always
like
what are you on about i didn't notice
anything
yeah exactly trusted trusted people yeah
show the trusted people you're finished
thing and then um they probably
like nine times out of ten they won't
even notice those tiny mistakes that
you've made
um yeah it's pretty crazy but it's true
it's true
we're going to answer story 12's
question as someone who's doing all
parts of game dev music art programming
etc how do you keep motivated when
you're learning a new skill specifically
how do you keep motivated when you know
you're probably going to be bad at it
for a good while you just have to
understand that it's a choice you're
either going to specialize in something
and be really really good at it
or you're going to be a
jack-of-all-trades and be kind of good
at a lot of things
and
personally
i mean i wish i can give you a better a
better answer but
i've tried to specialize like for years
i was really trying to fit the mold of
like someone who had a
a title and um was specialized and in my
heart
like didn't like it i got really upset
i tried to be
you know video only person and i didn't
like not doing game dev i tried to just
do game dev and i didn't like not making
videos
you know and throughout this whole time
i've always been singing and making
music and it just makes sense and that's
all i can say i'm not really thinking
about how good i am or how bad i am
i'm just thinking about what makes me
happy
so i guess it's just a really simple
thing of like
if you're enjoying it then does it
really matter
like if you're
really good or really bad
because you're gonna get better anyway
if you keep doing it does that make
sense oh here we go sid's asked the
question has there ever been a project
that you couldn't work on anymore for
whatever reason and just considered it
done and put it out there i feel like
that happens every single time
yeah like the the creative block
or
the law of a new idea
i guess there's a certain threshold
where i'll reach and if i'm like i'm
happy with well not happy but you know
i'm okay with that happy without
whatever yeah and they go yeah it's done
yeah
i mean yeah a lot of the time i know you
don't really do any documentation for
your stuff but
you'll have a vision of what you want to
make right
and then for me i usually do have a
document
and especially for like games there'll
be like pillars or whatever
so it's kind of like as long as you have
the main pillars so the main
features the main
meaning
behind whatever you're making as long as
that is fulfilled
then
to me that's kind of when i'm like okay
like it's done
i think
that might be it
we done
i think so so thanks very much for being
here
and i'll see you in the next one
have a lovely day evening and bye
say bye
[Music]
oh did you
yeah like this
what was that
[Laughter]
oh now your stream's caught up
you used to do it three times now
we don't dance whoa